one of the things that Donald Trump's
token military strike on a Syrian Air
Base was supposed to accomplish was to
erode the narrative that Trump is weak
on Russia despite the fact that Trump
informed Russia of the strike before he
even told our own Congress and further
damaging to this message was White House
press secretary Sean Spicer who seems to
be damaging to just about anything and
anybody that comes in contact with him
he literally called the hostile power
Russia which is currently under sanction
for interfering in our elections and
Ally and Ally here's Sean Spicer
yesterday work with allies including
Russian and committing to ensuring that
there are places that don't that are
free from violence what allies like
Russia now seconds later Spicer said
something that then suggested the
opposite Russia on the other hand stands
with Syria North Korea and Iran so are
they an ally or are they standing with
Syria North Korea and Iran or is it both
a lot of confusion on foreign policy at
that white house isn't there but I don't
think it's too far out there because we
still have trade and diplomatic
relations with Russia even though there
is a lot going on right now uh what
would be the correct term though you
know its adversary is too strong I think
it's a country that we don't have strong
diplomatic relations with I think I mean
I don't think that even if you have
trade with a country that by definition
means that they're an ally and this
further supports my assertion that the
serious strike doesn't tell us anything
big picture about what the Trump foreign
policy doctrine is there are people
reacting to this saying well what's
wrong with wanting better relations with
Russia that's a fine position to take an
argue right aside from the hypocrisy
relative to the right-wing view on
Russia before Trump selection but let's
put that aside at issue is whether Sean
Spicer's assertion is at all based in
reality right calling Russia and Ally
you can make the case that in some
hypothetical scenario we'd be better off
if Russia were an ally not everybody
would agree with that some people would
say no actually fundamentally Russia is
the type of country that we should
actually be allied with but they are not
currently an ally by any sensible
definition of the term I think there are
extraordinary circumstances which you
would call Russia and Ally for example
if you're uniting with them to fight the
Nazis okay but without those those
extraordinary circumstances that's not
the right word certainly doesn't apply
in 2017 and like with every um with
every Sean Spicer press conference
Spicer exudes sort of a frantic and
rushed nature constantly defensive
doesn't answer questions more than your
average white house press secretary
White House press secretaries are
experts in not answering questions but
Spicer does it in the frantic and
Confused manner that he genuinely seems
confused about just the basic facts of
what's going on and that's only one of
the reasons why i believe Sean Spicer
has irreversibly damaged his political
career by what he's been doing since day
one lying about that inauguration crowd
well we've talked a little bit about
who's going to be the next Trump
official to leave the administration
yeah I voted Sean Spicer and has been
all along I think it could be Spicer it
could be Reince Priebus we're hearing
there's sort of a shortlist for
replacement at one baman Bannon is
another possibility at one point I would
have said Kellyanne Conway particularly
in the 48 hours following her complete
fabrication of the supposed Bowling
Green massacre which didn't exist it was
it wasn't a massacre in the sense that
it didn't exist but she's basically been
removed from the public side so I think
that it's more likely now Pat that she
sticks around but we just never hear
from her again wait before you go on to
the next video because of the YouTube
advertiser boycott ads aren't playing on
our YouTube channel which means we are
no longer making any money from these
videos please help us fight back and
replace the lost revenue so that the
show can stay on exactly as it has been
uninterruptedly jus ever you can even a
dollar per month at patreon.com slash
david pakman show we need your help